hello and welcome to this video playing
cat fight so given bit ok let's go for
main line now let's try a 4 against the
ship a nickel recently study the game in
that line when Boris Gelfand that I that
I liked five how did girlfriend play
that
to play Bishop d3 here can't remember
anyway let's get going yeah I think one
thing that I remember is that rather
quickly on that night before and more
from can be challenged with night a to
an interesting moment now it takes with
the porn yeah I was wondering about that
if that's a good idea or not I wasn't
sure night coming to d3 can easily
expose that as some some kind of
weakness hmm okay
a TKE t5 now it will take with the e
porn hmm then maybe 45
hmm very difficult position I one day of
teaching and I push up f3 is an idea
maybe this is an idea this and then
Bishop f3 try to try to put some
pressure on g5 in case / c5 move he
probably wants to play c5 one moment
okay didn't expect that one is it good
actually wait I can take e 7 queen is
793 okay and this was one idea of 95
that it can't draw back to d3 now see 5
i'm going to check on d5 so he avoided
that played this one so i can actually
think about the exchange sack it's not
ridiculous
maybe it is back anyway i can go look
see one as well hmm
ok let's play that
still some yeah well no I can take on
before right or not why not see fire I'm
dropping back to the true
yeah t two or a three now I don't think
so let's go back and now I'm i have ya
que is taking it is it Queen f5 picking
up the next porn queen f5 Knight f6
Bishop g5 route 85 unfortunately ok so
that's not going to work but I can go
for p3 next check the pause quickly
trying to break down that that pass on
see form yeah or him getting a big
center in return ok so here thought
queen bee three years should be good
back rank is worrying me a little bit
who takes a force maybe a move no I can
take on d5 ok so no problem one minute
36 I never looked at the clock IAM
chicken c8 so that good let's chat
insert that now quincy three maybe
still don't like my back rank have to
play some g3 h3 soon you cannot take a
four because of rugby one this is this
is a real shame so okay let's make sure
that I'm not been Greg made it
time morning its let's play it simple
so was there some kind of tactic that
I'm overlooking I'm not sure let's just
I'm just playing it really really in a
simple way now looking at the beep on
and d5 week so both at the same time
should be difficult for black to handle
time is also an issue so simple it's
probably a good here if it goes 96 at
some point i have h form make sure that
next so that 95 is not happening that's
a useful move anyway so let's see if i
can trade this and then get at the d5
pawn
I can take with the bishop actually
you're just going to take every pore now
three pawns black resigns ok so i yam
epic rank was worrying me but in general
I think it also looked look decent yeah
taking with the paunch in 95 yeah i mean
i think what is better the before porn
is a weakness at least it should be good
enough for the small advantage Bishop
here yeah that's an interesting
interesting moment alive the move but I
think the critical reply must be c5 this
is really not doing much I could have
taken just twice anyway here we should
be 797 queen before there would have
been much much much simpler so c5 is
critical and I'm not quite sure about
this I thought well if I go look to you
one he actually has you form and this
sort of doesn't make much sense it's
difficult to prevent yeah I was thinking
this might also be a movement yeah
sometimes I Queen here but 94 seems to
be okay yeah that was the moment here to
go see fire and this is a mistake I
actually could have done this which is
even better than then my move which
isn't bad but the other one is better
just winning the pawn straight away
let's server lucky yep yeah we have c1
yeah Bishop yet to go I think Bishop
went here damn him if he takes it and
this is given by by the engine now it's
not much fun to play you're just sitting
on those weak points but he has to do it
yeah it's really just a big porn for no
particular for nothing in particular
check yeah just what is the engine
giving this move check I can go Quincy
one actually okay so this is actually
not so bad okay even though the rooks
are both unprotected black has no double
attack okay well g3 wasn't bad i think
it keeps a very substantial advantage
with those very weak points and I could
have taken the rook actually yeah I was
somehow at one moment they had less time
on the clock and I was getting into
let's play quick let's play simple mode
and if I get an N kimber three extra
pawns I'm taking that okay thanks for
watching